Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
La forêt de Chantilly,
vous la connaissez,
vous vous y promenez,
vous l’aimez,
vous y fabriquez vos souvenirs.
C’est sûr, elle nous relie.
Alors on la pense éternelle et on a tort.
Je suis forestière en forêt de Chantilly
et depuis 500 ans,
des forestiers avant moi,
il y en a eu des centaines
et il y en aura encore beaucoup d’autres
dans les siècles à venir.
Je sais que je suis le petit maillon
d’une très longue chaîne
d’hommes et de femmes
qui prennent soin
des arbres et des forêts.
Un chêne, ça met plus de 100 ans à mûrir.
Alors pourquoi parler maintenant
de ce long fleuve forestier tranquille ?
Eh bien, il se passe ici,
comme partout ailleurs sur la planète,
quelque chose que
ni la Terre, ni les hommes,
n’ont connu aussi fort et aussi vite :
le réchauffement climatique.
Depuis 1990, c’est 1,5 ° C d’augmentation.
Par le passé, à la fin des glaciations
qui ont eu la peau du mammouth laineux,
il fallait 500 ans
pour que ça se réchauffe autant.
On a reconstitué le climat jusqu’en 1680
et on a confronté ces données
aux archives du château de Chantilly.
On peut l’affirmer,
cette crise est inédite,
elle est grave et on la sait
désormais permanente.
La forêt de Chantilly en souffre au point
où elle pourrait mourir et disparaître
d'ici la fin du siècle.
« Mais alors, me direz-vous,
comment ça se fait qu’une forêt
puisse disparaître
sans que l’homme ne la détruise
ou ne l’arrache volontairement ? »
Eh bien, chaque espèce d’arbre
a des exigences très précises
en température et en pluie.
Les arbres sont très dépendants du climat.
Retenez qu’un arbre,
c’est un buvard géant.
Par capillarité, (Aspire)
il va drainer l’eau du sol
et (Expire) la restituer
à l’atmosphère par ses feuilles.
Et c’est au cours de ce processus
que la sève va le traverser
et qu’il va pouvoir se nourrir
des éléments minéraux du sol.
Et le drame, c’est que
plus l’air est chaud et sec,
plus l’arbre, en fait, va drainer
cette eau du sol pour la restituer.
Son besoin en eau augmente.
Ainsi, un arbre adulte peut être traversé
par jusqu’à 200 litres d’eau par jour.
Or, depuis 2015, la pluviométrie
et les réserves en eau du sol
ne suffisent plus à alimenter ce besoin.
Il manque désormais à notre arbre
125 litres d’eau
pour alimenter la circulation de sa sève.
Ce faisant, il ne peut plus se nourrir.
Il puise sur ses réserves
et il finit par mourir de faim.
Son ombrage n’est plus assuré.
Le sol est désormais exposé
au soleil et au vent.
Et s’il n’y a pas tout de suite
de jeunes arbres pour prendre le relais,
eh bien, ce sont des herbes,
des fougères qui s’installent
et le blocage devient écologique.
La forêt a disparu.
Sachez que quand même,
tout n'est pas fini.
Il existe des endroits où des arbres
savent très bien s’adapter.
Dans le sud, vers la Garonne.
Mais voilà, tout ça, c’est très loin
de la forêt de Chantilly.
Il faut retenir que la forêt,
actuellement,
elle a 47 000 gros bois de chênes
qui sont en train de mourir.
Et ce faisant, nous perdons
des semenciers,
c’est-à-dire des parents acclimatés
qui sont capables de produire des semis.
Mais nous perdons aussi notre capacité
à investir pour préparer un futur,
car c’est normalement
la vente régulière de ces bois
qui finance la reconstitution de la forêt
et également son entretien.
Alors revenons à nos arbres
du sud vers la Garonne.
Il y a des arbres qui, eux,
vivent très bien les sécheresses
et qui se plairaient vraiment beaucoup
en forêt de Chantilly.
Mais voilà, les forêts,
elles avancent en laissant tomber
des graines un petit peu plus loin.
Elles avancent en fait
en installant des semis.
Et le processus est lent,
100 mètres par an.
Alors, avec le temps,
les arbres du sud
finiraient bien par arriver
en masse à Chantilly.
Mais il faudrait sept, neuf mille ans
et d’ici là, plus de forêt.
Alors, puisqu’on sait ce qu’il faut faire
pour remplacer les arbres qui meurent,
vous me direz : « Plantons,
au lieu de disserter sur une scène. »
Eh oui, mais on plante quoi et comment ?
Car on ne sait pas trop comment
ça va se passer tout ça.
Nous voilà nomades climatiques.
Ici, en 2050, nous aurons
le climat de Périgueux.
Et toujours ici, en 2070,
nous aurons le climat d’Albi.
C'est demain pour notre troupeau d'arbres.
Alors il va falloir le guider finement
pour le garder vivant.
Et ce n'est pas la seule responsabilité
du propriétaire, c'est aussi la vôtre.
Même si vous roulez en voiture électrique
en rentrant de l'aéroport.
En attendant, les forestiers
sont déjà en ordre de marche.
Les années à fruit, ils récoltent.
Ils mettent tout cela en culture.
Puis ils transportent les plants,
ils essayent de les mettre au bon endroit.
Pendant des années, ils pouponnent
en espérant que ça survive.
Et pendant ce temps aussi,
eh bien,
il y a des besoins
qui augmentent en reforestation.
Et nous ne pourrons pas
planter suffisamment.
Alors il va falloir mélanger
la régénération naturelle
avec probablement
des espèces d’arbres cousines
qui seront mieux adaptées
aux conditions futures du climat.
C’est la nature qui fera le tri,
nous, les hommes.
il faudra qu’on récolte intelligemment
des arbres qui vont mourir
en protégeant le sol et surtout en
essayant de le garder à l'abri du soleil.
Alors ce que je vous propose,
c’est de remettre la forêt et le matériau
bois au cœur de nos projets de société,
parce que la survie des forêts sera
le meilleur indicateur de notre réussite
dans le pari de la transition écologique.
Je vous explique.
Le carbone dans l’air sème
le désordre dans le climat.
Or un arbre, ça mange le carbone
et ça le séquestre dans son bois.
Tant que ce carbone
est capté dans le bois,
il arrête de semer la zizanie
dans l’atmosphère.
Et peu importe sous quelle forme
ce carbone est gardé prisonnier,
sous la forme d’un parquet,
d’un meuble, d’un livre,
d’un tonneau à vin.
Peu importe,
l’essentiel, c’est de le relibérer
le plus tard possible -
20, 30, 100 ans -
et surtout de le recycler
le plus localement possible.
Filières courtes, arbres,
forêts, bois, recyclage,
tout ça, ce sont nos alliés
pour le climat
et non des choses qui s’opposent.
À Chantilly, 160 bénévoles, des élus,
des habitants, des chasseurs,
des professionnels, creusent,
décrivent des insectes de la canopée,
mais aussi les arbres,
la végétation, les sols.
Ils réalisent énormément d'échantillons.
Ils plantent de nouvelles espèces
qu’ils mesurent
et toutes ces données
vont servir à 40 chercheurs
qui vont pouvoir croiser leurs savoirs
pour mieux comprendre
les réactions de l’écosystème forestier
face au réchauffement.
Ce faisant, nous espérons pouvoir
mieux anticiper et qui sait,
trouver quelques petites parades.
A Chantilly, on a décidé
de rester éclairés par la science
et surtout de conserver notre expérience
et de la transmettre
aux générations futures.
Vous l’aurez compris,
garder sa forêt vivante,
c’est regarder au-delà de l’horizon facile
que l’on a quand on se promène
avec des amis,
juste en allant
à la chasse avec les copains,
ou parce qu’on est content parce qu’on a
bien vendu son mètre cube de bois.
La forêt de Chantilly,
à l’instar de toutes les forêts,
est un tissu fait de nature,
de culture et d’économie.
Si vous retirez une seule de ces mailles,
tout tombe en charpie.
C'est ça que je vous invite à venir
découvrir sur le terrain et dans l'action.
Votre forêt est un patrimoine de vie
co-construit, patiemment accumulé,
génération après génération
d'arbres et d'hommes.
Le mauvais vent du changement
climatique se lève
et nous prenons conscience
que la forêt est menacée
alors même qu’elle est
indispensable à l’espèce humaine.
Eh oui !
Elle nous fournit des tas de biens
et de services gratuitement :
des matériaux,
de l’eau, de l’oxygène,
de la biodiversité et de la joie.
Ah ouais, la joie !
On avait oublié ce que c’était
dans cette ambiance de guerre,
de Covid, de décroissance programmée.
Alors prenez vos enfants, votre chien,
allez en forêt et regardez-les.
Et vous vous souviendrez :
le bois, le carbone, l’oxygène,
le chant des oiseaux.
Il y a de l’amour
et de la magie autour de vous.
Ce dont la forêt a besoin,
c’est d’une collaboration entre l’homme
et la nature autour d’un projet commun.
À Chantilly,
c’est ce qu’essaye de construire
le collectif
« Ensemble Sauvons
la Forêt de Chantilly »,
un laboratoire à ciel ouvert où on essaye
d’imaginer la forêt de demain
et surtout d’oser la tester.
Alors maintenant, chez vous,
ensemble, sauvez votre forêt.
(Applaudissements)